this morning we remember a TV performer
who inspired generations of children
even though they never saw his face
on screen puppeteer Caroll Spinney
played Big Bird and Oscar the Grouch on
Sesame Street he died yesterday at his
Connecticut home he was 85 fans built a
memorial at Big Bird star on the
Hollywood Walk of Fame and last night
the Kennedy Center Honors gave a nod to
spinies decades-long career as the
Kennedy Center Honors celebrated the
legacy of Sesame Street Big Bird was
front and center the show's cast members
all wore yellow feathers to remember
Caroll Spinney the man who spent nearly
50 years as the iconic canary they say
what do you do I said well you've heard
of Sesame Street
hi Big Bird Spinney was born just
outside Boston in 1933 he started
puppeteering as a kid but it wasn't
until three decades later than an
encounter with Muppets creator Jim
Henson helped him land a life-changing
role I nearly laid an egg right here on
Sesame Street
Big Bird debuted on Sesame Street in
1969 the puppet was more than eight feet
tall and the five foot ten spinny used
his hand to move its mouth as Big Bird
became a household name so did another
of Spinneys characters the grumpy albeit
endearing
Oscar the Grouch
[Music]
Spinney retired from Sesame Street last
year what kind of bird are you oh well
I'm a big yellow bird in October we
spoke to his successor 49 year old Matt
Vogel about the puppeteers influence
what did you learn from apprenticing
under him I learned about how Big Bird
is this innocent kind sweet curious kid
and Carol is like that as well when he
retired spinny said he hoped Big Bird
helped make the world a better place
[Music]
for being my
I learned from Matt just how what an
incredible creation Big Bird Carol's Big
Bird was because you know it's
physically it's an incredibly demanding
job to extend yourself so that you're
essentially an eight-foot bird that
costume is is quite heavy also the
character of Big Bird was kind of a
goofball at first yes Nene made him kind
of a big child it's sweet endearing
character yeah legacy he left us you
sure did Wow